on this clip you're gonna see the
amazing alan tudyk that is it gives
voice to k2s Oh which is the Droid very
funny performance - amazing
really funny this this droid is
hilarious and you have a good comedic
energy with destroyed well the thing is
he was tough to not laugh in front of it
I mean he's very funny but he was also
wearing these very tight pajamas and and
he's in stilts because he's huge you
know it's an imperial droid was
programmed so he's huge and you're
standing next to his balls you know you
should bring him to your to the shows if
you can show you the the size of yes yes
yeah you had me at Paul you know yeah I
am there Diego let's take this one why
does she get a blaster and I don't what
I know how to use it that's what I'm
afraid of
give it to me
we're gonna Jeddah that's a war zone
that's not the point of man would you
get it I found it I find that arms are
vague and unconvincing Trust goes both
ways
[Music]
you're letting her keep it would you
like to know the probability of her
using it against you
[Music]
is high it's very high
[Applause]
you